et
bien lors de l'appel du 18 juin 40 je me
trouvais ça bordeaux où je terminais des
études puisque je préparais en 1940
école navale et je dois dire dire que je
ne vais pas entendu l'appel du 18 juin
et que ma décision était déjà formé et
que j'allais partir quelque part pour
combat et ce n'est que le lendemain
qu'on m'a parlé d'un appel un général
français j'ai tout de suite mesuré ce qu
est l importance de cet appel est décidé
de me rallier à l'autorité se doter d'un
chef qui pourraient est susceptible de
vous entraîner au combat
c'est une réaction de jeunes qui
voulaient que j'ai et et nous avons été
nombreux d'ailleurs
par les jeunes à nous manifester
mais nous n'ont pas eu tous la
possibilité de réaliser notre ambition
qui était celle de rejoindre dès le
départ les forces françaises libres
alors quel est votre sentiment
aujourd'hui alors que vous célébrez ce
18 juin à fort de france
écoutez les sentiments que j'éprouve ici
sont liés bien sûr à l'idée même que je
me fais du 18 juin
il y a certes la manifestation du
souvenir mais au talent manifestation du
souvenir elle même il ya quelque chose
de plus profond il y avait dans le 18
juin
le refus fondamentale des fausses
fatalité il y avait à travers des
négligences des démissions politique est
un désastre militaire sans précédent la
volonté d'affirmer notre identité
nationale c'est être
il faut bien le dire un très gros effort
entamé ce film mérite du général de
gaulle le 18 juin n'a pas été si vous
venez le jour de la divine révélations
en réalité les uns et les autres et pas
en nous portons en nous comme les
prémices d'une révolte intérieure
devancé successives des missions
nationales et bien sûr il a été je
dirais le 18 juin le jour le lendemain
du 17 c'est à dire de l armistice celui
où l'explosion s'est faite au plan
national
affirmation d'identité nationale et puis
aussi
affirmation pour nous de vouloir la
rénovation de l'état et je crois que ce
sujet est d'actualité il est permanent
pour nous c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui au
delà de la manifestation du souvenir il
ya eu une invitation à la réflexion pour
chacun qui est extrêmement important je
dirais presque que maintenant si ce
souvenir est cher bien sûr aux
résistants ils nous dépassent toutes
deux très largement et pour atteindre
des dimensions nationales et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il convient de
faire des manifestations invitant les
uns et les autres jeunes et vieux et et
je dirais et tous répartis quelle que
soit leur activité professionnelle
sociale à méditer sur les leçons de cet
événement pour la martinique je dois
dire que je suis très heureux d'être ici
parce que j'ai parfaitement mesuré
pendant ces périodes difficiles qu'elle
avait été ma chance relative de pouvoir
dès le départ me donner à fond cette
entreprise j'ai pu mesurer ce qu'avait
été le le long et lent et difficile
cheminement des antilles pour pouvoir et
aussi participer et dès qu'ils ont pu le
faire d'ailleurs elles l'ont fait de
manière généreuse il n'est que de voir
les traces que nous avons pu rencontrer
sur tous les champs de la tâche des
raisons pour laquelle vous comprendrez
que sur le plan du coeur je sois heureux
de me retrouver aujourd'hui on ce 18
juin
1976 à fort de france
[Musique]